welcome to washington i'm bret baer
breaking tonight serious news police in
boulder colorado dealing with an active
shooter situation
at a grocery store just breaking over
the past
few minutes we're going to get the
latest now from chief breaking news
correspondent trace gallagher in los
angeles good evening trace
brett good evening to you that grocery
store is called king supers which also
happens to be in a very busy mall
and a business center on table mesa lane
and south broadway if you know the area
we have seen video of people who appear
to be badly injured
on the ground both inside and outside
the store we do not know the severity
of their injuries but there are several
ambulances on scene
and medical helicopters also in the area
witnesses say they were in the store and
they could hear
a series of powers of smacks gunshots
over and over
some of them ran out to the back and to
a nearby fire station for safety now
we saw swat teams go into the store
with barricades you know those hand-held
barricades that kind of walk in
and then a short time later police
escorted one person
out of the store he was not in handcuffs
he appeared to be an
older gentleman then later another
person without a shirt
was taken away in handcuffs and was then
placed onto a medical gurney
we're not saying there were two shooters
or suspects because police have given us
very little information
and remember if you don't know how many
shooters might still be in the store
everybody who walks out automatically
becomes a suspect and in fact
we saw a large group of people who were
in the store
were eventually let out by police with
their hands in
in their in the air kind of like we have
seen at many school shootings the man
who was
cuffed though did appear to resemble the
description witnesses gave police and
it's also notable
that even though a potential suspect may
have been taken away swat teams are
still up on the roof of the grocery
store and the surrounding buildings
and more tactical teams are still
arriving but we did see some police
officers on the ground take off their
helmets
an indication that the situation does
not appear as intense
now as it was just a few minutes ago and
just for a little perspective if you
know the area this is a couple of miles
from the university of colorado boulder
it's also a few blocks from a very large
high school
neither of those places appear to have
been affected and again
we expect the police and authorities to
brief
on this brett sometime in the next 45
minutes
to an hour breaking news as it comes in
right okay
okay trace we'll head back for any of
that we'll take that press conference be
our own jeff paul is on the way to that
scene and once he gets there we'll take
that as well